hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
starting a coverage of the second most
important tournament of the year that is
the candidates tournament winner of this
tournament will go on to face magnus
crossing for the world championship the
most important term of the year that's
going to be held in november tournament
starts today on march 10th it's going to
run through march 28 2018 there are 14
rounds so a lot of chess to be played
eight competitors and each of those
competitors will play their opponent
twice one is the white pieces one is the
black pieces if you're not familiar with
how players qualified for this
tournament there's quite a few ways to
go about doing that one is if you lost
in the last world championship you're
automatically in so that's why we have
sergey cardiac and he is in the
tournament he's the 13th break player in
the world we also have the top two
players from the chess world cup in
2017. that's lavon aronian fifth ranked
player in the world and dean leon the
11th ranked player in the world then we
have the top two finishers in the grand
prix we've been covering that
tournaments for the past couple years
and we have shakira mahadev he's the
second ranked player in the world and
alexander grishik the 12th ranked player
in the world they both qualified from
the grand prix then we have the top two
players as far as raiding who played in
the world cup in the grand prix that
didn't already qualify that is fabiano
carjuano eighth ranked player in the
world and wesley so the fourth running
player in the world and then lastly the
eighth player is a wild card given out
and this year was given to vladimir
klamnick he's the third ranked player in
the world so definitely have some strong
competitors we have sergey karjakin who
took madness carlos in the distance
before at the very end losing to magnus
carlsen uh but very strong competitor he
won this candice tournament last time
out two years ago and then we have the
second third fourth fifth ranked player
in the world so expecting some fireworks
in this tournament
round one we're going to be looking at
fabian carjuana the american versus
wesley soh wesley still playing the
black pieces karwana playing the white
pieces and they have it structured where
while you do play every player twice you
actually play your fellow countrymen
early on in the tournament fabricar
juana if you remember a couple years ago
was just a day away had a chance to
actually win the tournament so he's
going to be looking for some revenge
knowing how close he came to playing
magnus carlsen back in 2016. so we will
go ahead and get started with fabiano
playing the white pieces starting out
with pawn to d4
so plays knight to f6 pawn c4 pawn e6
pawn g3 so getting into the catalan
opening is fabian carjuana
bishop down here b4 bishop to d2 says
hey if you want to exchange that's fine
bishop comes back to e7 fiance on the
king side of the board pawn down to d5
knight f3 and then castle on the kings
side so so had the option to play more
of a classical line taking
this pawn here on a c4
instead decided to play the closed
variation uh in morphs in two after
castle on the king's side a semi-slav
defense right here his lightsaber bishop
is not outside the pawn chain uh so in
this particular opening
black's really looking to control the
light squares of the board and then
later push on the queen side the board
as he usually has an advantage on the
queen side and white's just going to be
looking to continue his development uh
he does have
more of a presence what is his light
square bishop here on g2 to attack a
semi-slob opening where black's trying
to control the light square so we will
continue queen here to b3 this does
control the center light squares it also
attacks this pawn here on b7 if the
light square bishop on c8 ever does move
knight to d7 bishop up here to f4 so
white had a few options here he could
have played knight two c3 which is
pretty common instead decided to go and
play bishop up here to f4 this does
allow him if he ever wants to play
knight to d2 he does have some options
here pawn down to a5 and this is
where white has more options you know
many times if you see pawn two a5
immediately it's going to be met with
ponza e4 i still think that's a good
move here you could see pawn to c4
really trying to squeeze black uh not
give wesley so much material uh much
room to push forward at all
since he played bishop up here to
f4 uh maybe he wants to now play knight
to d2 i think this makes a lot of sense
decide to play something a little bit
different that's rook to d1 and this is
not a common move that you see in this
variation it is a very sound move
getting your rooks involved into the
center of the board to protect these
central pawns but
you know fabian carjuana he's taken less
than a minute on every single move so
definitely seems like this is part of
his preparation these players have been
preparing for this tournament for a long
time you know we only have the
candidates it's been every other year
now so waiting two years
most of these players have something up
their sleeves and so no surprise five
card juan are not playing the typical
moves but playing them extremely fast
not really thinking about he's prepared
ready to go knight to h5 the bishop
comes back here to c2 does not want to
bring it back here to e3 blocking his
pawn on e2 from ever get involved and
then you can tell the the rook here on
d1 just want to protect the pawn here on
d4 so bring it back to d2 doesn't make a
lot of sense decides go ahead and bring
it back here to c1 and then right back
to f6 now the knight comes up to d2 and
then pawn to b5 and this is what we
talked about where wesley so is looking
to start to push on the queen side of
the board he starts to get a sense from
fabiano carjuan his bishop back here on
c1 is sort of blocked not really doing
too much and so he figures this is the
best opportunity that he has to start to
push on the queen side have some sort of
attack as black fabiano pushes forward
with pawn to c5 wants to make sure that
no additional material this knight or
this bishop can get involved into the
game
so plays pawn to b4 and then queen to c2
and this is the first move where fabiano
took more than a minute it took 16
minutes trying to make sure that he got
this right but it seems like wesley so
has gotten him out of his preparation
and now they're really just playing
chess we do see wesley so if we come
back a few moves when he played uh the
pawn to b5 that was when he took 17
minutes you could really tell that he
was trying to analyze the position was
not prepared exactly for where they were
on the board so after queen to c2 i get
into what i would consider the middle
game as both players out of preparation
we're out of opening lines now just
comes to okay how does your setup work
against what your opponent is trying to
do pawn to a4 wesley so continues to
push on the queen side of the board rook
to e1 getting ready to push this e pawn
in the center pawn to e5 and this is
really the most aggressive line that
wesley still could take here as far as
you know where could he go from here he
could get his queen involved queen to a5
uh could just play more safe queen to c7
if he wants to get his bishop involved
bishop to b7 uh while you know it's not
doing anything right now it does protect
these light squares instead of the board
later on once some of these come off the
board this light square could do a lot
of damage could see rook to a5 many
times if you're not exactly sure what to
do you'll play a safe move what i like
to look at is pawn to h6 you can't
really mess things up too bad here this
does stop the knight coming up here to
g5 uh and just kind of waits to see what
your opponent is doing doesn't put
yourself in a tough situation at all but
wesley so looked at this and said yeah i
found a good line i'm gonna go ahead and
blow up the center of the board he's
already pushing on the queen side so he
has some some threats over there now he
decides okay i don't want my opponent to
really control with these two pawns on
the dark squares so i'm gonna try to
change the game here and play pawn to e5
knight takes knight takes here pawn
takes you may say okay gave up a pawn
here but the knight to d7 is the move
that wesley so found it allows him to
really counter attack and he's gonna
have a pretty good control of the center
of the board with his pawn so he's
attacking both of these pawns
and it really comes down to how fabiano
wants to defend decides to go and play
knight to f3 protecting this pawn here
on e5 that's completely okay with wesley
so plays bishop down here to c5 gets
that pawn back immaterial now he has a
pretty active position this bishop is
also defended by the knight on d7 so the
queen's not going to be able to attack
that knight up here to g5 and this is
one of those moves that i like because
you know this knight is attacking the
square here on e5 uh and the knight
coming up here to g5 says i no longer
want to defend that at the highest level
play this is fairly obvious to look at
and say okay something's going on here
and you can probably already see that
queen up here to h7 is checkmate but
this is one of those moves that uh you
know knight to g5 is still an extremely
strong move it's being protected by the
bishop here on c1 and why not just try
this out against your opponent sometimes
that when you're not playing the highest
level players you will see mistakes uh
you know the terrible would mistake
would be queen to g5 because they could
usually see that that's being defended
but some players will look at this pawn
and say okay this is undefended i'll go
ahead and take that but then queen up
here to h7 it will be checkmate well not
everyone's going to fall for that you
can expect wesley so not to fall for
that you know it is a very good move and
that's why fabian decided to go ahead
and play that pawn to g6 is the response
and then bishop up here to f4 so since
wesley still didn't fall forward does he
need to make sure that he is protecting
this pawn here on e5
black plays queen down here to
b6 and this is double barreling here
with the bishop and the queen both
eyeing down on this square here on f2
which is only being protected by the
white king here so fabiano does have to
respond he plays pawn up here to e4 does
two things you can see one it opens up
the door for the queen to protect this
pawn it also tries to counter attack in
the center of the board recognizing that
right now wesley still has the upper
hand and he needs to find a way to claw
back and actually get some sort of
momentum and start to attack his
opponent instead just let wesley so run
him over we see pawn down here to b3
pawn takes pawn retakes and then queen
over here to e2 and then bishop a6 i
really wanted to see and i thought we
would see as soon as the queen comes
over here this pawn on b3 can be a
nuisance for white to deal with and rook
down here to a2 makes a lot of sense you
always want to get your rooks on your
opponent's second rank if you're black
if you're white you want to get them up
here to the seventh rank it just always
puts pressure on your opponent they
usually have some pawns of sorts unless
they've pushed all their pawns most
people haven't uh when the rooks are
coming down here so we're gonna always
be pressuring this pawn right here and
then depending on you know what white
does he's usually gonna have to spin
some material to actually defend this
rook over here to b1 and then we can see
pawn two d4 all of a sudden this pawn is
a past pawn really going gonna start
putting pressure on his opponent
now if he wants the light square bishop
can get involved into the game it's
behind the rook instead of blocking the
rook this really gives wesley so the
upper hand as far as the attacks go but
in the game decided not to play that
plays bishop here to a6 does attack the
queen but it does block off his rook
from coming down to that second rank
queen up here to f3 this is really where
fabiano wants the queen to be
it is
everything is defending this light
square diagonal in the center of the
board bishop comes down here to a c4
rook takes rook takes and then pawn
pushes forward on e6 and you can tell
even from this position it looks like
fabiano now has
the aggression he's the one pushing his
pawns onto difficult territory for
wesley still to deal with and you don't
no longer have to worry about a past
pawn from wesley so or any huge threat
right now that could change but right
now fabiano's done a good job of you
know seeing that bishop to a6 getting
his queen to the right spot and then
attacking as needed we see the pawn take
and then the pawn take up here on f7 the
bishop takes and then the knight takes
on e4 and this is where things start to
get pretty interesting because it's so
tough to analyze some of these positions
these players get into and make all the
correct moves the bishop comes down here
to d4 in the center of the board it's
attacking this pawn here on b2 but the
knight up here to d6 is so tough to deal
with and there's so many things that it
does one of the things is it opens up
for this rook to get involved into the
game it also is being defended by this
bishop here on f4 but there's a lot of
critical squares that this knight on d6
is blocking one of those is the square
here on e8 so the rook can't come over
here to e8 and exchange off the rooks
that would be very good for black
that knight stops it's attacking his
bishop so many times a player will move
the bishop here but that's just going to
allow white to have a stronger attack
going forward so from here we see the
bishop come down here to d5 and then
queen down to e2 and while it looks like
the queen is retreating
also what this is doing is starting to
gain a huge momentum boost for fabiano
carjuan to start a huge attack
black really has to worry about these
bishops coming off the board on the
light squares and the queen coming up
here to e6 um you know if black's not
careful depending on where his rook ends
up the rook could come up here to e8 uh
this dark square bishop would come over
here to h6 uh and this rook could get
involved into the game start to attack
his opponent's king so this is a very
tough position for wesley so to play out
of
we can look at a few options of how
black could continue we talked about it
the bishop comes down here to g2 and
takes okay queen up here e6 check this
is going to end in a mate king 2h8 it
would be made if the the king just came
over here to f8 because queen to f7 will
be checked but now knight to f7 check
forces the king to move knight to d8
this is a discovered attack so this
knight opens up the door for the queen
and also blocks the rook which is very
very important in this
attack queen back here 2h8 and now queen
up to e8 check uh and then we can get
the rook involved in a very quick mate
after that let's say we come back and
say the the bishop's not going to take
but maybe the knight's going to move
knight to c5 uh rook 2 d1 attacking the
bishop just so much material being
attacked for black
queen down here to b4 this does defend
this material uh and still keeps that
queen in the center of the action bishop
takes on d5 pawn takes and then queen up
here to e7 uh now let's say the bishop
takes on b2 there's just no way to stop
all of the threats that are going on
bishop here to h6 uh and this is just
preparing so many different threats we
have queen to
f7 that's going to be uh extremely bad
for black as you can see queen over here
to
g7 if the the bishop can come off the
board is another threat that we have as
well as the knights getting involved in
the game as well so this would be a very
easy
game for fabiano carl juana in the game
we see wester so not play any of those
he decided to play knight to f8 and
while
you know he would really like to be in
the center of the board he's in full
defense mode right now he knows it uh
and he's just trying to hold on as much
as possible fabiano continues bishop
takes on d5 the pawn recaptures and then
queen to f3 and this does a couple
things the first thing is it activates
this rook to get involved into the game
so it's going to be very easy for the
next few moves rook to come up here also
the queen attacks this pawn here on d5
as soon as fabiano can take this pawn
check the opponent's king and start a
strong attack it's pretty much gonna be
game over from there we see the queen
come down here to a5 this is attacking
the rook here on e1 which you always
want to defend and attack at the same
time that's exactly what this does
defends the square here on d5 and
attacks this rook here on e1 so the rook
comes up to e7
and from here wesley so decides to go
ahead and rethon resign there's just no
way to hold on to this you know if he
were to
from here play uh rook to a7 try to
attack okay
bishop here to h6
uh this opens up the door for the queen
to come over here to f8 and take and
mate that's gonna be bad if he doesn't
play that let's say you know that this
knight clearly is just gonna get gobbled
up from the bishop coming to h6 so if he
were to play uh knight to e6
okay well now we have bishop down here
to e3 uh and as you guys are probably
aware by now this bishop to e3 doesn't
really care about this bishop on a d4
it's just opening up for the queen to
get involved into the game uh and so we
see
okay sure queen down here to a1 king to
g2 rook to f8 and then here's that
dagger move of rook 2 e8 it says yes you
can attack my queen that's fine but i'm
going to make your life very difficult
so queen could come up here to a7 i
recognize some of the moves could be
different but showing you some of the
situations people always ask oh yes
someone's resigned why did they resign
how could the game continue this is one
variation that could go down rook takes
on f8 the knight takes and then a queen
up here to d5 this is the dagger move
where you know once the queen is in the
center it's starting to attack there's
just not much that can go
well for black from here so could start
gobbling up material here knight down
here to f5 the pawn can't take if the
pawn takes it's going to be a quick mate
from here checkmate if the pawn doesn't
take then the king could just come back
then we see bishop two h6 and then just
gonna have to lose more material at the
end of the day black's going to end up
losing so wesley so decides to resign
and fabiano carjuana wins the game
getting out the gate strong so
congratulations to him we do have so
much more chess 13 more rounds for all
these players wesley so definitely not
out of it starting in the canon starter
against some of the best players in the
world playing the black pieces sometimes
that's just how it goes so he's going to
look to regroup tomorrow but hope you
guys are excited about the canvas
tournament we have so much good chess
excited to bring you as much coverage as
possible but thanks for watching and
i'll see you guys in round two